[Musique]
on a marqué qu'au maître gims fait tous
notre gueule
merci à mm merci baba et c'est comme ça
qu'il a payé sa villa à marrakech
attention pour eric photo le barca aura
sera francis lalanne abba supprimera
sera alors presque la dose maximale me
faut alors on rappelle que dark assez ce
qui est drôle simpara fera ses skis en
bois sont moins sympa et je me rappelle
ces cultes tu l'avais il y avait eu un
problème avec lui probablement
c'est une de mes embrouille préféré de
toi ce que tu en as beaucoup toi tu es
un petit peu le beau spencer talbot
regarder les belges pour moi c'est mais
vraiment au bord du délit culturel quoi
voilà je ne tarissent pas à me juger
toi tu es toi tais toi et on essaie de
se détendre normal détente est foutu si
jamais tu te fais en colère tu es foutu
fais-toi conscient
le travail la victoire tu fais c'est de
la merde tu te prends mais tu sais je
suis un poète heureux et je t'emmerde
et
c'est le meilleur argument est le plus
développé la soirée mais des fois il
était au point soleil est que non mais
c'est bien il était chaud non mais moi
je voulais vraiment assez clair il
voulait vraiment pété la gueule dans les
coulisses on sera mal mais bon ces cas
là il faut attaquer les bottes beaucoup
de talent on veut normalement il était
hors de contrôle était out of control
comme on dit en anglais
quand vous tard avec une photo regarder
michel denisot michel rasle on peut voir
la photo ci haut pays alors là ils sont
ils sont figés l'armée soit de mise au
barca ou passera barkhordar cas parce
qu'on va rappeler c'est l'animateur du
grand journal à l'époque vous faisiez
dame faisait la bande à fifi et c'est là
que tu t'es fait connaître du grand
public on a récupéré un sketch devant
kad merad à l'asra
est ce que tu vas voir le sketch ou pas
ben justement cette race sera je pense
non mais tu veux le voir on va pour
faire rire et les gens vas-y allez on y
va
ouais voici en exclusivité le bébé de
gamme
[Applaudissements]
venir me faire un bisou
[Musique]
m
bisous
[Musique]
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
ce marquage ce et des gaules sedar
mais toi quelque chose ça très
d'arcachon désolé elikia cette photo
date uva d'arca aura sera tout autant
d'anciens look et plus beau maintenant
ouais en venir à ce sera parce que j'ai
fait une grosse j'ai fait de gros oeuvre
dans ma vie c'est commencé le foot et de
l'arrêter il faut pas arrêter le foot
mais celles ci n'ont pas bon pour le
fise ironie les filles on préfère
maintenant franchement cette photo c'est
lors de ta première télé c'est en 2001
passait pas avoir un sur france 2 dans
l'émission des mots de minuit trappe à
des modélisations philippe lefait le
temps dormait avec sa maman dormait et
que ça j'étais content mais il y avait
mardi
quoi vous l'avez beaucoup regardé je
m'endormis ce que je dois dire un peu
pour ma défense
si on peut faire le test ici toutes les
fabriques jeunesse ça fait assez mal on
est tous des gars en général ça c'est un
peu tout le problème la différence avec
toi c'est qu'on est resté league comment
on faisait pour pécho l'époque puis
chanté par séoul imputé mardi soir
encore on a péché que c'est avec la tête
et de cliquer c'est le kit c5 encore
apprendre à tricoter avec des gants de
boxe quoi je suis tu enlèves les gants
de boxe à votre non pas que ça va
beaucoup j'ai commencé à pécho avec des
gants de boxe et maintenance valérie
vous auriez peut être séduite par eric
parce qu'il a bien il aime la
littérature il est c'est un brillant
esprit donc moi forcément mais il est
beau dans les esprits c'est un mec on
est on est on est content d'être avec
éric nolin physiquement il pas
dégueulasse non plus pas très bonne
[Rires]
clame depuis des années on se connaît
très bien travaillé ensemble il admire
on n'est jamais d'accord et c'est pour
ça qu'on s'adore passé six ans comme moi
et bernard de la villardière défend
toujours eric naulleau c'est vrai alors
tiens pour tarek tient carrément tarek
regarde cette photo toi oh la la
l'union cgt d'arc à paris
serra sera parce que c'était pas mon
dessin ah oui pour tous les gamins en
fait on passait à la chaîne et futuniens
le pinceau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur ce gris tepa s'occupe du front de
seine avant de venir choisir ton
cuillère attention eric photo suivante
allez on y va laurent ruquier c'est ton
patron quand tu étais à on n'est pas
couché dark dark dark attend toujours d
accueillir les gens de la télévision
j'ai vraiment percé professionnellement
grâce à lui nous on n'est pas couché là
vraiment ce serait de l'ingratitude
assez basses et rhône-alpes en plus
grosse que je pourrai bon il m'a fait
rencontrer jean luc lemoine ça pourrait
éventuellement un petit moins quand même
enfin par rapport à l'océan de est
amorcé c'est vraiment vraiment fait ça
vous vous cautionnez ça vous dérange pas
du tout ce qui vient d'ailleurs non mais
je vous aime comme beaucoup aimé et
demain c'est votre anniversaire
oui c'est vrai donc c'est moi je serais
très gentil toujours partie de l'inviter
contredit les chroniques à la part
concernant david harari
on a tous voila non la photo d'une photo
ou d'une photo de nom alors eric zemmour
c'est pour vous dar kaoua sera non
bédard cas par cas à un type avec lequel
tu peux t'en gueuler ça fait onze ans
que je fais équipe avec lui at il est
d'accord sur rien bah quasiment que rien
saurait sauf sur le fait que les rolling
stones sont un meilleur groupe que les
beatles seulement voilà ces voix là et
tu peux t'en que les onze ans avec
quelqu'un ça fait onze ans que fait
l'équipe sans jamais que ça dégénère
d'arc à quoi j'ai plutôt bien alors
tarek y en ait une photo toit pour toi
il ya un commissaire tourner autour char
tu regarde et on a la vidéo non j'avais
un droit de regard si on mettait la
vidéo pas la balle je veux pas la perdre
on a déjà nos numéros
ah bon
dit pas tout tu peux nous montrer les
messages bah quoi y'en à n'importe qui
bien c'est à dire
mes parents regardent la télé ce soir
est jamais leur dire que j'ai trouvé ma
femme
[Musique]
jamais le même site
[Applaudissements]
il ne s'est jamais rien passé refait on
s'aime vraiment bien mais on est très
copain mais c'est tout offert beaucoup
[ __ ] de ma gueule encore combien
d'années toi à ce jour c'est vrai tout
cas si ce que ce soit fait ou pas j'ai
envie de te dire dieu bénisse et marques
comme vraiment aimé ça s'est jamais fait
ça s'est jamais fait d'accord battant
banon mais bon c'est vraiment ma tante
et sur le dos de miss provence pas que
vous en voyez beaucoup
qu'est ce que tu as contre les femmes
moches au fond non mais non là c'est un
peu comme on dit non alors il ya un truc
je suis pas bien non mais il ya un truc
qui me court après qui me suis hyper
grave
pourquoi mais miss provence et la copine
de max et non mais lui je veux dire
c'est pas parce que tu passes devant un
magasin avec son regard d'arsac que
c'est le tien banny c'est pareil il est
conduit tomber dans les mains et
regarder la météo on se connaît on sait
on si on se connaît et alors marion non
on est fans amis on a mis ça c'est parce
que vous savez qui se sont échangé des
messages à sa commande de ces ça
commence vous savez ça ah oui c'est vrai
comme chez
il s'en tire bien alors patience au
massachusetts et ipad macro pour eric à
le président d'arka embrassera le
compliqué ça comment tu sais qu'on sait
envoyer des messages non j'attends de
voir attend de voir c'est la corse et
sur la tranche d'accord j'aime bien le
côté dégagisme bas mais débarrasser d'un
paquet a envie de voir est vraiment faut
voir là c'est un peu je n'envie dois je
me faire des bébés témoins photo dr yann
moix pau erick yann moix dar kaoua sera
non d'arca parce que je trouve qu'il a
qu'il a réinventé à lui seul le métier
de chroniqueur ce qui fait personne
n'avait jamais fait certes il part dans
un truc complètement personnel on s'en
fout ton de tous les codes de la télé
pour ça c'est vraiment ses rares ballons
il a du talent rembourser les
chroniqueurs chacun a sa personnalité on
arrive à faire un truc mais inventer
quelque chose comme il le fait je trouve
que c'est un bon après il peut énerver
et brigand voilà je suis pas là c'est
pas assez
il y avait une brouille allert était
invité dans les dents on n'est pas
couché tu te rappelles ou pas vous y
prit la tête
mary king ouest vous êtes en vie de la
foi ou pas moi quand je vois ça j'ai
envie de 2d mais la corrida tiens oui
mais vous savez naïveté d'auteur je
pense que les critiques en face de moi
sont pas contentés de regarder la
couverture mêlant ou la burqa du fonds
mais ça aurait été bien pire la place en
bleu touche le monde en parle et on va
le toucher du doigt
j'attends que vous disiez quelque chose
j'ai déjà quelque chose mais peut-être
vous n'avez pas entendu vous avez
peut-être louis sélective
enfin bon je sais pas si l'honnêteté
intellectuelle fait partie de votre rue
alors vous savez vous pouvez faire
beaucoup de reproches c'est ce que
j'essaye de mettre en avant c'est le
médecin qui n'ont simplement ayez
l'honnêteté de reconnaître je n'aimais
pas finalement et critiquer si j'adore
mais ben non
donc est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce
qu'est un vrai critique pour vous
puisque vous en est ainsi je comprends
bien une bonne chauffe il ya une bonne
ambiance mais christine angot tout ce
temps pour ce dakar ou accra serra sera
parce qu'elle a réussi à me rendre car
on pressent que sympathique j'ai une
photo pour toi et à tarek tarifs fait
cette photo à tranquebar cas par cas de
retard alors tu te rappelles où on a on
a trouvé tu sais rappelle toi
ouais non mais c'est râpé c'est râpé
j'ai trouvé en son nom mais en second
degré en second de la web et surtout
qu'on t'a stage trouve un truc que tu
rappelait regarder j'aurais même sur le
terre terre en hélicoptère qui est
toujours cassé des boules
entre dans la danse rejoindre dans la
ronde j'arrive en france
vance comment tu comme le roi du monde
[Applaudissements]